well hunger is the ultimate expression
of poverty and that's why there are
still almost at this stage billion
people suffering from hunger every day
that hunger is a combination of acute
malnutrition but that's a small
proportion that's less than ten percent
and the really serious problem is
chronic malnutrition about ninety
percent of the about a billion people
are suffering from chronic malnutrition
and it's it's about people being caught
in a desperate poverty trap and they're
not at the moment able to get out of it
and I think the challenge is to see find
ways of both dealing with the immediate
problem and also then helping people out
of the f of these poverty traps that are
stuck in we're very focused on on the
whole area of acute malnutrition and we
were very instrumental in developing a
different approach to dealing with that
called community therapeutic care which
has been adopted last year by the UN as
best practice but we're also dealing
with the whole area of chronic
malnutrition and that's where we're
trying to really break the cycle and
that cycle involves women who pregnant
mothers who are underweight and badly
nourished producing children who are
underweight and particularly in the
first two years of life if children are
not properly nourished they're already
stomped income's in there and there's a
huge proportion of the children in the
countries we work in are affected by
stunting and that means mental and
physical stunting which is irreversible
so really that's a key focus as well and
then at the other end of the scale as we
people we're trying to find pathways out
of hunger for people people you know who
if we can improve their livelihoods if
we can get them earning that little bit
extra amount of income then you know
they can grow their own food and they
can really help themselves out of hunger
many of the countries we work in are
working in very fragile climates and
particularly areas like the Horn of
Africa Ethiopia Somalia northern Kenya
Darfur Chad all of these are very
vulnerable places where climatic change
and you know where we're facing into
more of this I'm making the lively
farmers livelihoods much more vulnerable
the rains that don't come on time or
that call me regularly and sometimes
come to 422 it too much rain and shorter
growing seasons all of these things so
we're looking at you know different ways
of how we can help that and and some of
that will will involve looking at
pastoralists lifestyle like lifestyles
because many of these areas in those in
those environments are dealing in the
past pastoralists setting and finding
solutions to their problems is certainly
one of the things we're doing to deal
with hunger on a long-term and
sustainable way it's it's a lot more
than about either increasing
agricultural production or tackling the
immediate problems of malnutrition it
really is about trying to look at this
in a holistic way obviously health it
has a very critical role to play in
terms of what some of the methods in the
whole area of child survival so making
sure that mothers are properly have good
health and and small children are
properly both nourished and some of the
elementary causes I mean when you look
at it and we have close to 10 million
children a year die under the age of 5
10 million children under the age of 5
die every year and more than half of
that is caused through a combination of
malnutrition and easily preventable
diseases so if we're to make the biggest
most quickest in fact that's where we
have to start and then when you get into
education if you take a longer-term
perspective here one of the critical
things is educating girls and that has
been shown again and again to in
development terms to give about the
highest return you can get so dealing
with hunger has to
in an integrated way tackling the
immediate food problem but also
investing in education and health
I think there remains the issue of
keeping a very clear focus on it at both
national and international level I mean
and and having policies in place to deal
with it because policy matters here and
political will to provide the resources
to to fund policy change but it you know
we have we had in our in Ireland
recently something called we had the
Irish hunger task force which was asking
the question you know what can I erlend
as a country do to really make an impact
on the problem of work hunger and we
came up with two core priorities the
first one was dealing with tackling
nutrition of the mother and child under
2 years of age putting a great deal more
emphasis of that nuh grating more focus
on it and the second one was putting in
much greater emphasis on improving the
productivity a small-scale African
farmers and that's a role for government
in Africa to really change policy on but
also they need the support of the
international community to come in and
and basically fund improved policy to
achieve to do that